when you're losing the argument you
start insulting people
this is true in elementary school
playgrounds
this also happens to be true in 2018
in the white house democratic
congressman from california adam schiff
is undoubtedly going to be playing a
major role once democrats take over the
house
in january he's been the ranking member
on that house intel committee which ran
a completely bogus investigation into
donald trump at the time
it was headed by republican devin nunes
who was literally
running to the white house to tell
donald trump what they were doing
well the tables are turning in january
and adam schiff is likely going to go
from being second in command
to being the chairman of the house
intelligence committee
trump knows this trump knows that he's
in deep
trouble with the competent adam schiff
in charge there and
adam schiff has also said that he thinks
the installation of acting attorney
general matthew whitaker
is not constitutional trump is furious
and he's now ewing now using childish
ad hominems reminiscent as i mentioned a
minute ago
of playground insults that like
eight-year-olds
might come up with trump went on twitter
and i'm allowed to say this because it's
not the swear word this is
s-c-h-i-t-t said quote so
funny to see little adam [ __ ] talking
about the fact that acting attorney
general matt whitaker was not approved
by the senate
but not mentioning the fact that bob
mueller
who is highly conflicted was not
approved by the senate
again i'm i'm saying s-c-h-i-t-t i'm not
saying that banned word the fcc
it's a name they can't come after me
okay there's actually a legal argument
to discuss here
um which is that bob mueller as i said
earlier
is just doing an investigation he
doesn't need to be approved by the
senate
to do an investigation he doesn't have
regulatory power he can't decide policy
this is just an attempt to conflate
robert mueller not being senate
confirmed to run an investigation
with the attorney general not being
senate confirmed
to be the top law enforcement officer
who is in a policy setting position
and that is a major difference and again
to take it a step further
mueller was confirmed by the senate for
his prior role
as fbi director now the easy criticism
is oh trump is childish and vindictive
but that's always been the case the more
precise analysis is that
trump is scared and panicking but he
continues to embarrass himself
and degrade the office of the presidency
he could simply be truly
mortified about what might happen in the
next two years
when democrats take over the house adam
schiff yes
has gotten under trump's skin and he's
about to get
way more powerful and would actually be
able to maybe
maybe hold trump accountable and trump's
lashing out and in a way
getting one of these pet names from
trump means you're doing something
serious you're having an impact crooked
hillary
crazy bernie adam [ __ ] i'm forgetting
others as well right pat on the
who oh yeah nickname on the left well
left and right remember
uh there was lion's head and there was
little marco
but it funny enough trump seems to know
how to spell little now which is nice
because before he was spelling it
l-i-d-d-l
apostrophe so that's one bright side
if there's anything that we can say that
has improved about trump's ad hominems
is that they seem to be slightly
more grammatically correct or something
which is
maybe like the weakest silver lining pat
has ever found
in many years of looking for and finding
silver linings uh listen trump scared
trump's scared
and i hope that schiff is able to get a
lot done in january and only time will
tell
i am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by
blinkist.com pacman
blinkist is a really unique service for
your phone
tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy
blinkist takes the best and most popular
non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audio books i'm sure that if you're like
me
you have a very long list of books that
you've been meaning to read
you only have so many hours in the day
and that's why blinkist is so amazing
they take the most important information
the themes the insights from each book
and they distill it
into a 15-minute audio book that you can
listen to in one sitting i've listened
to
a ton of books on blinkist our audience
can get a
seven day free trial by going to
blinkist.com
pacman if you're watching on youtube i
put a link in the description
i have listened to blinkist books about
economics
about political science about history
about science
so many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audio books for about
five bucks a month go to blinkist.com
pacman that's b l i n k i s t
dot com forward slash p a k
m a n